so years ago many many years ago when I
was I'm gonna introduce the guy I can't
wait I can't wait I can't wait either
many many years ago I did a I did The
Tonight Show the only time I did it
mm-hmm
and a couple of days made three or four
days later Barry Katz calls me Mommy I
have a client you know he wants to talk
to you he's Asian but he lives in New
York so I haven't called me you called
me and this has never happened before in
the history of me being in the comedy
business we rock another comic who I
don't know calls me just to compliment
me Wow right so he calls me because hey
man I'm from New York I'm half Korean I
saw your Tonight Show I think you killed
it man you know when I come to LA I'd
like to meet you and hang out and
whenever I've never had that happen and
this [ __ ] did that no hostility no
hostility it was at that time it was
okay yeah yeah at that time it was built
on pure love just low 60s love okay even
with the [ __ ] flower in the gun right
you know I mean they grew their hair out
from their pits down to their knees he's
a great stand-up I've done tours with
him before I've done many shows with him
we've been in battles we fought and
where we scream at each other but you
know he's been in many battles actually
you had an infamous battle with Dane
Cook outside his apartment one time
remember that ladies and gentlemen he's
a headliner I'm from Pittsburgh
originally and he's a dear friend and
I'll know her I'll know him for the rest
of my life his name is Steve burn give
him a round of applause
welcome thank you thank you thank you
thank you you're welcome
okay yes um thanks for doing my podcast
yeah I feel like I've done it already
yeah
has he done the podcast oh you've talked
about him so many times I have episode I
do talk about you a lot yes yeah yes
have I said good things No
that's just a bad thing no yeah those
things get back to me but I I know you
though so I don't I know how you are so
I don't oh how am i well even when you
said like we've had our battles yeah
okay I think I come at things from like
like a pragmatic kind of like you know I
don't get my emotions involved I think
when we talk there have been times where
emotionally I'm confused by the
decisions you've made but I just say
I've never liked when we've argued I've
never left a conversation good saying
you just burned a major bridge I have
this [ __ ] like that and I've said that I
said that you said that to me as you
walked to like a Corolla and sped out of
30 miles per hour of the company okay
yeah my car has nothing to do with this
[ __ ] kind of business I burned a
major bridge yeah a Hollywood power
player Bobby Lee Toyota Corolla yeah
speeds away Prius what was it before
Corolla you're right thank you
I'll tell you what a great friend this
is yeah he knows I love Oasis love races
this is one of the things that irritates
me but I again I like I don't I don't
get I don't say you burn a major bridge
I just go that's Bobby his car your car
broke down or something yeah I did your
car broke down
yes thank you probably that night as he
was leaving yeah and then I had a
Hyundai Santa Fe at the time and I'm
just are doing this purple know is
silver yeah so the reason why that was
purple I'm not from Minnesota so I lent
it I said hey you take my car I'm going
on the road you use my car while I'm
going does that so I think about what
who does a comic Randolph whatever a
friend a friend whatever a friend when
you burn the bridge you Brit Brit
Burnett it takes time to rebuild time to
rebuild right so so I lent him my car I
get back in my car and I go to play my
Oasis I go where's my Oasis DVDs not
one not two like three Oasis DVDs I call
the I go CDs I go Bobby where's my oh I
threw them out the window
Oh Mike why we because I told you
because you don't listen well I love you
my car no I know you are
yeah and I let you die garden this is
who I deal with no you know bad guy but
that's the thing I got on anyone you
guys ready for another right and then
we'll move on to other things okay but
you don't [ __ ] listen right I don't I
don't like the band okay
was it a why even hampered all over the
[ __ ] thing like the like it's a flyer
for some sort of [ __ ] nightclub or
something you don't like awaits as we
watch it look at now I love him now but
at the time I didn't like them I thought
they were like too poppy
oh my I like them now I apologize how
much money do I owe you 60 bucks nothing
now okay yeah